how's it going with my name is Farah
diba welcome to ask a brigade it's a
demo called neverending nightmares I've
been one of the places for a long time
it just never happened
I can't out of that but I'm playing now
and I'm looking forward to it it looks
gorgeous and you bros oh I'm a sucker
for pretty games so that's I don't know
why he chose this fund but yeah it's
still early development sigh I'll
forgive it I'm sure he won't use it
again ah chiller is like a comic sense
of horror fonts I even think that
typical horror fans are pretty ugly but
this is just like no it doesn't matter
so he needs our help to make this game
it has a Kickstarter if you like to
throw money on things go and check it
out and or even if you like things you
can throw money on it just do whatever I
got my game fire ready let's do it hey
girl you don't look too happy
oh yeah I'm not happy when that happens
to me either
okay cool it was a dream my game pad
this piece of [ __ ] never works what do
you want from me axe backs fine I'll
play with a keyboard dirty [ __ ] my
keyboard is a dirty [ __ ] I'll never
forget
so developer this game home I don't want
it I feel like this is a sensitive thing
I don't say the wrong thing but I think
from my understand is that he has
suffered from mental illnesses like
depression I don't know if that
classifies it but and he's he wanted to
give people the player the same feelings
he had throughout this game which is a
pretty interesting thing and he wanted
to use it as a way to help people who
suffer from these illness I'll this stop
talking about this cuz I feel like I'm
not probably not saying what the real
thing
and yeah don't take my word for anything
ever that goes forever hey you go how
you doing is that really an eagle I
don't think so it's like a gone I don't
know what it's called in English oh
let's go down no we're not going down
what is this a note hmm okay so the
colored objects means I can interact
with them but it looks like we'll need
something else okay we're going here old
Mike the game really looks even better
like when you actually play it on a full
screen it looks amazing it looks like
I'm not do that much I have a sweet ass
pajama that's oh [ __ ] this is creepy
this is really creepy why would you keep
dolls like this ah jeez this is so
unsettling
okay we're not gonna be on GC just
follows around OG creepy little mouth
what is up
Oh No
okay that's an I want i watch is pretty
hot
hello man what am i doing up oh the
house that they're unsealing gum it's
you what are you doing here okay oh oh
it's my shadow
it's my shadow we're fine we're totes
mcgoats fine it's kind of we're gonna
make it out of here alive rice I know
exactly what I'm doing
can't even get my stupid Xbox controller
my walking circles it feels like it all
right last door what do we got it's that
Slenderman did you really see that
that's totally a Slenderman reference
okay oh I don't like this room [ __ ] that
room
we need a lighter or some [ __ ] like that
hopefully we'll find it in here yes
so small I'll be taking this with me
hello gentlemen I'm talking to the chair
Oh
all right let's go we got we got our we
got our cess
oh it's raining
what
you have forsaken me
what the hell did I do someone killed my
evil twin thank you
okay well I don't like this room I'm
going now
okay I'm going back to bed I don't like
this
but it's lending oh my god holy [ __ ]
okay I'm not okay with that boobies
thank God boobies oh [ __ ] ah no I hate
this room what is that woman what hey
hey them spooks I can't handle let hey
okay alright god I hate you no well no
one likes columns actually I got a
finite parking word on Wikipedia like an
a cool guy beautiful
oh [ __ ] I thought we made it cut my
shoulder this is not my shoulder by the
way I'm an idiot okay if we make it out
of here libraries I want you to know
that I love you and and I would love to
go to McDonough's with you if you pay of
course okay the dolls are gonna do
something can I ride this horse horsey
horsey can I ride you I was gonna give
this game ten out of ten but I can't
ride the horse so I'll give it a leaven
out of that now just kidding okay let's
go
he's thinking the poopoo hey soldier
okay I'm pretty sure there weren't as
many of them was it
if someone's [ __ ] with me right now I
don't like when you [ __ ] with me
wasn't there a basement or some [ __ ]
like that
I think we have to go to the basement
but I don't want to go to their basement
we probably need an axe for those here's
the basement okay hi hi it's just
booty paw what am I doing with my lap oh
the hacks advice thank you
wait I can only hold one of them Oh Jeff
not also looking at Nia there you are
what the hell is going on this is so
creepy
I like this no I don't what are we doing
with accent was it blood of the axe I
never heard daddy wine okay I like the
the Victorian style bath bathtub it's
pretty sweet I would love to sing in
that bathtub I don't even know what I'm
saying when I do it all right
I heard chains unless it's two chains
actually it's bad either way whatever
chain there is I don't want to know
about it oh the lights are turning off
after me why was that and think so
Oh Oh was it
what's this all we did really this long
that's so confused right now
well that's the badass here don't mind
if I sit down
no I can't pretty sure it wasn't that
long but hey
all right let's chop chop chop chop
Haley eight all right let's go up oh
that was fast
hello ah
I have an axe don't you dad come near me
don't kill me just hanging around huh
just don't kill MIT where's my axe oh no
no I want more come on come on that was
short ah okay
I think I'll definitely back this on
Kickstarter I think it's it looks like I
get a fun game scary
least so unsettling I love it they like
you've enjoyed watching Bros hit
subscribe overwrite today I'll see you
in the next one let me know if you
wanted me to play the full game when you
can hopefully it comes out and in the
next video
[Music]